[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
phantom téléguidé on suit la foule à 3
les journaux télévisés tout s'écroule
autour de moi
moi que peut-on voir seul dans le noir
dans le tonnerre se ruer les enfants des
môles va vite des nuits sans sommeil
sens-tu le vidotto imaginer sa vie
dans un élan d'un mot
[Musique]
et comme il en arrive à oublier
dans un décor inanimé sinon comment
faire semblant schubert
ainsi non
soyez dans l'incertitude des lendemains
et piloter
au milieu du bitume sous un soleil temps
baisser la tête ramasser les miettes les
faire semblant de rêver
puisqu'aucune 2001 qui pourra rien
changer
sortu rêver d'autres imaginez sa vie
dans un élan d'amour
[Musique]
pas mal non
arrivé
perdu dans ces disciplines dites moi
quand j'avais 15 ans
comme un enfant
primé dans un décor raffiné
[Musique]
comment fait semblant
citant dans mon arrivée mary louise
oubliée
dites moi comment faire semblant jeu
mais signe des temps comme un enfant
abîmé dans un des cas réanimer du mois
comme en baissant blanche me plaît dans
la main sur du temps
[Musique]
la machine du temps
et je me perds dans la nuit de temps
iman est resté à l'âge des coûts merci
mon soulagement
la coupole j'adore l'image
qu'est ce que ce qui si mal est ce que
tu veux pas me faire un petit kiff tu
peux pas me faire padam padam j'adore
c'est une de mes chansons préférées les
au monde du monde
je te jure que c'est vrai sens du terme
ben ali bien sûr je sais pas ce matin
chasseurs n'ont soit et de ma mère la
nuit du haut de ma tour la tête dans les
étoiles mais lendemain à l'école
[Musique]
maman me disait fais tes devoirs je
répondais attendez moi
il veut venir chacun de mes poèmes un
jour à krim mp papa je te dirai que je
t'aime parce que c'est ton anniversaire
vidéo l'embrasser à la version steam ali
et était paniqué on était pas de leurs
jouets des ailes et les chéris ya un
truc douce kaitos human sait qui sera le
7 avril 2018 au zénith c'est pas ouf
quand même au zénith de paris
[Musique]
il est actuellement en tournée dans
toute la france et à bouderait bon cc
voilà c'est le premier album ça cartonne
et c'est vrai il ya merci d'avoir été
avec mais on vous kiffe aussi et le
titre est fabuleux et toi mme sartre est
la coiffure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'elle est c'est mal fait
très mal on encore des fous